[Music]
the noble consciousness being the
extreme which is the self appears as the
source of the language by which the
signs of the relation are shaped into
animated holes the heroism of silent
service becomes the heroism of flattery
this vocal reflection of service
constitutes the spiritual self
separating middle-term and reflects back
into itself not only its own extreme but
also reflects back into this self the
extreme of universal power making that
power which is at first only implicit
into a power that is explicit with an
existence of its own makes it into a
self conscious individuality the result
is that the spirit of this power is now
an unlimited monarch unlimited because
the language of flattery raises this
power into it's purified universality
this moment being the product of
language of an existence which has been
purified in the spirit is a purified
self-identity a monarch for such
language likewise raises individuality
to its extreme point
well the noble consciousness divest
itself of as regards this aspect of the
simple spiritual unity is the pure
intrinsic being of its thinking it's
very I expressed more definitely it
raises the individuality which otherwise
is only a presumed existence into the
existence of its pure form by giving the
monarch his own proper name for it is in
the name alone that the difference of
the individual from everyone else is not
presumed but is made actual by all in
the name the individual counts as a pure
individual no longer only in his own
consciousness but in the consciousness
of everyone by his name then the monarch
is absolutely separated off from
everyone else exclusive and solitary as
monarch is a unique atom that cannot
impart any of its essential nature this
name is thus the reflection into self or
the actuality which the universal power
he has in its own self through the name
the power is the monarch conversely he
this particular
individual thereby knows himself this
individual to be the universal power
knows that the nobles are not only ready
and prepared for the service of the
state power but that they group
themselves round the throne as an
ornamental setting and that they are
continually telling him who sits on it
what he is
here in paragraph five 11 we see Hegel
now returning to the thematic of
language and he's going to talk about
one modality of language in particular
translated as flattery Schmeichel right
right this this form of language in
which one reduces oneself while
increasing something else and this is
going to lead us to the unlimited
monarch the the absolute monarch you
could say I think what he has in mind
here are the sorts of claims that were
being made not only by say louis xiv
but also by some of the English kings
and and other monarchs who had similar
pretensions what's going on here is
really a jockeying for power and not
simply political power but but a
different deeper you might say sort of
power reflected in the speech acts of
language themselves between the the
people belonging to the noble class who
presumably are motivated by this noble
consciousness which could include those
who rise up through the ranks you know
show a certain heroism he talks about
the heroism of service and the growing
power of the state encapsulated in the
person who is at the apex at least in
some cases as a figurehead because there
could be other powers behind the throne
so Hegel says this noble consciousness
appears as the source of the language by
which the sides of the relation are
shaped into animated holes what is he
talking about there you notice that
we've got a somewhat similar schema here
on the board as that in the previous
paragraph except what I've done is sort
of turn things 90 degrees so that state
power was you know previously split into
these two things the abstract Universal
the common good right and then the the
will that had to actually decide things
and this will was in in certain ways not
quite formulated yet it's going to start
getting its its formulation its
articulation through
what the noble consciousness is doing on
the other side we have the noble
consciousness as you know the obedience
that was gaining honor the the person
sort of identifying themselves with the
state power sacrificing that their own
selves being virtuous and then we had
this individuality of the eye that was
never fully you might say suppressed or
left behind or worked through that was
always there in the background and here
I'm just gonna leave it as the eye
because what's what's happening is in a
certain sense in a Faceman of the eye
through flattery so he's saying look the
language is actually coming from the
nobles and it results in this this
effect of the unlimited monarch so he
says the heroism of silent service
becomes and isn't this a funny phrase
the heroism of flattery there is still a
kind of self-sacrificing taking place
but now it's it's occurring in language
in the social dimension rather than in
the realm of action the noble
consciousness is rendering something
like obedience rendering something like
honor to the the sovereign to the to the
person in charge right in the past
though what was going on as they were
getting there was an exchange they were
giving service and they were getting
honor and self-respect through that here
in a certain way the nobles are being
made less active they're not being made
less noble at least not on paper but
they are being defamed one of the things
that louis xiv did that was particularly
smart on his part although it did have
far-reaching effect was to say okay no
they don't get to stay in their own
territories and rule over their domains
from there because if they do they're
too liable to raise private armies and
get themselves mixed up in all sorts of
seditions and Affairs and private feuds
between each other and we don't want
that sort of thing happening in our one
single country there's one ruler
everybody else needs to fall in line so
what do you do you bring all the nobles
to Versailles and you have them hold
court and they you know engage in all
sorts of diverting activities which cost
lots and lots of money this is sort of
the unintended side effects but for the
moment it looks like it's quite a
successful strategy so the heroism of
silent service becomes the heroism of
flattery says this Volkl reflection of
service constitutes the spiritual self
separating middle term so in the
previous paragraph it was spirit that
was mediating right now it is language
and the language is coming from the
noble consciousness now of course you
know the noble consciousness this is a
little bit of an abstraction the normal
conscious is not doing this totally on
its own it's drawing on the language
that it has I'm sure there's other
people involved as well you know the all
the the apparatus of human beings and
material that's required to make the
noble consciousness have the sort of
platform that he or she does but it goes
on he says it reflects back into itself
not only its own extreme but also
reflects back into this accept this self
the extreme of universal power here's
the really important development making
that power which at first is only
implicit into a power that is explicit
with an existence of its own so you know
what we could say is it's it's not
really the case that the unlimited
monarch becomes the unlimited monarch
because somebody you know comes along
and says well crap I don't want to have
any more of these revolutions or
rebellions or private feuds or
what-have-you taking place in my demesne
estoppel
no the initiative is actually coming for
Hegel here from the side of some of the
nobles who are perhaps not even
realizing what they're doing by
increasing the power of the sovereign
and creating somebody who now it becomes
state power as a person you know when
louis xiv says l'état c'est moi
i am the state that's a perfect example
of what what's being talked about here
so what has been lacking before this was
that state power existed and it it
functioned but it didn't have this self
conscious will of its own recognizing
itself as a self conscious will becoming
the dominant polarity in the entire
thing so that now the the king or
whoever else is in charge can say not
only am i the state i am the common good
service belongs to me
flattery belongs to me so this is
something that the the flattery of the
nobles makes finally explicit like he
says he says it makes it into a self
conscious individuality and the result
of this is the unlimited in Barranca if
i remember right
monarch unconditioned the the one who
does not have limits placed upon him or
her unlimited he says why because the
language of flattery raises this power
into it's purified universality that is
a really interesting observation
why not unlimited because the king has
all the guns why not unlimited because
the king holds the treasury unlimited
because of language unlimited because of
the way culture functions
this is a really important point when we
talk about Hagel as being an idealist
I've said many times that Hagel his form
of idealism stresses that ideas have to
become actual but there's another side
to it which is to say ideas matter
sometimes so much that they do become
actual by virtue of being ideas you
could say you know whoever has the guns
gets to decide everything but know it's
the person who can talk the person who's
got the guns or the swords or whatever
it happens to be the poison gas into
obeying them into recognizing them as
legitimate authority that has the power
so this is a really important point here
and let's go on he says this is an
unlimited monarch why because we have
this this other this purified'
universality this moment being the
product of language of an existence
which has been purified into spirit is a
purified self-identity a monarch why
because such language raises
individuality to extreme point now
notice that that Hegel does not say that
the unlimited monarch becomes the
unlimited monarch because of the
flattery of the people or because of a
social contract or because everybody all
got together and recognize that things
were more effective this way and this
guy should be in charge and blah blah no
he says it's the myth the nobles who are
in the position to be able to through
their flattery create the unlimited
monarch as unlimited monarch through
their language because their language
matters their word matters and now we
get to something that Hegel is going to
talk about here which is very
interesting and we'll sort of rebound
back to the the nobles in just a moment
but at first it belongs to the unlimited
monarch he says that expressed
definitely it raises the individuality
into an existence of pure form how by
giving the monarch his own proper name
now what does this mean you know that
they're able to say this guy's Fred or
this guy's Henry yes but his Henry is
different than all the other Hanks out
there the Monarchs name matters in a way
that's different than everybody else's
name
that's what Hegel's saying here in this
passage look at how he portrays that he
says here we go it is in the name alone
that the difference of the individual
from everyone else is not presumed not
just posited but made actual by all in
the name the individual counts as a pure
individual no longer only in his own
consciousness we're all conscious of hey
I'm Greg and there's lots of other
Greg's out there but I'm this Greg I'm
you know it's probably other Gregory B
Sadler's out there I know there's plenty
of Gregory Sal there's a ton of Greg
Sadler's because it's a common name but
I am Gregory Sadler the the you know
YouTube Haegele guy all right that's
that's more of a name in the sense that
Hegel's talking about here but now we're
talking about somebody who actually has
political power who controls the state
the the one that the state is really
oriented around this could be a king
could be an emperor could be whatever we
want we don't even have to call it royal
names just could be the the ruler and
the ruler is the one who actually gets
to have a name in this sense so he says
by this name the monarch is absolutely
separated off from everybody else
exclusive and solitary as monarch he's a
unique atom that cannot impart any of
its essential nature the name in this
sense becomes the marker for somebody
who is totally unique within
the political community within the
Commonwealth the one who drives the
state power the one whose will
determines the state power and the
nobles have moved from a service of
action to a service of flattery a
service of what might we call this here
the Hegel doesn't use the term
recognition on their cannon right and
it's a one-sided recognition what we see
here is in certain respects a
replication of what we saw previously in
the Lord of the world and you know the
the person who ends up controlling
everything in the unhappy consciousness
right so he goes on and he says this
name is the reflection into self or the
actuality which the universal power has
in its own self through the name the
power is the monarch there's something
about being able to be articulated and
the name could take place not just
through speech or writing but perhaps
even just through the seal right
all of this enables the unlimited
monarch to actually function in the way
that he or she does
so he says conversely he this particular
individual thereby knows himself this
individual to be the universal universal
power they understand that they are in
the position of power and what is it
that they know about the nobles the
nobles are oriented around them they the
nobles in effect hold are well they
don't hold court there held in court
right they are they're made to just show
up he says he knows that the nobles are
not only ready and prepared for the
service of the state power but this is
where it gets really interesting they
grouped themselves round the throne as
an ornamental setting like jewels in a
setting all right and that they are
continually telling him who sits on it
what he is the person who sits on the
throne is continually being reminded by
this service of who and what he is
the role the function that he has and
his uniqueness in occupying that role
the language of their praise is in this
way the spirit that in the state power
itself unites the two extremes it
reflects the abstract power into itself
and gives at the moment of the other
extreme the being for self that wills
and decides and by so doing gives it a
self conscious existence or otherwise
expressed this individual actual self
consciousness attains to the certain
knowledge of itself as the power of the
state it is the point of the self into
which the many points ourselves through
renouncing their own inner certainty are
fused into one since however the spirit
proper of state power consists in its
obtaining actuality and nourishment from
the sacrifice of action and thought by
the normal consciousness it is an
independence that itself alien is the
normal consciousness the extreme of
being for self receives back the other
extreme they had an actual universality
in return for the universality of
thought which it relinquished the power
of the state has passed to the noble
consciousness in it then power is first
made truly effective in the being for
self of the noble consciousness it
ceases to be the inert entity which it
appeared to be as the extreme of
abstract being in itself considered as
it is in itself state power that is
reflected into itself or has become
spirit simply means that it has become a
moment of self consciousness that is it
exists only as superseded consequently
it is now essence in the form of
something the spirit of which is that it
is to be sacrificed and surrendered that
is it exists as well it does indeed
at the same time you have the continuing
existence as in reality visa vie wealth
into which it is ever-changing in
accordance with its notion but it is a
reality whose notion is just this
process of passing over by way of the
service and honor done to it and from
which it derives its existence into its
opposite into the relinquishment of
power thus the fuel yourself that in it
that is its will knows that through the
debasement of the noble
consciousness it has become a
universality that rouses itself has
become a completely separate and
contingent individuality which is at the
mercy of every more powerful will what
remains to it have universally
acknowledged in communicable
independence is the empty name
paragraph 512 begins by talking about
language the language of praise but then
really is shifting back away from
language you might say into the
dialectic and the metaphysics of what is
happening or the social dynamics if you
prefer having to do with state power and
ultimately reintroducing something
that's been in the background this
entire time well remember this is the
dialectic of wealth and state power the
noble and the base consciousness so by
the end of this we'd better see both
wealth and the base consciousness the
ignoble consciousness coming back in so
he tells us that the the language of
their praise is the in this way the
spirit that the state power itself in
the state power itself unites the two
extremes what are the two extremes the
extreme of the abstract Universal the
abstract power right and the other
extreme the being for self that wills
and decides now why is Hegel not at this
point just talking about say the common
good or the apparatus of the state and
the unlimited monarch when he just
brought this that in in the previous
paragraph because being for self this
category of being for self is going to
be something that we're gonna find now
in the noble consciousness and also
dealt with in terms of of wealth which
is coming back into the scenes so he
says what what's happening here is that
the state power has a self-conscious
existence right he says otherwise
Express this individual actual
self-consciousness the absolute monarch
attains to the certain knowledge of
itself as the power of the state and
whenever we see certain coming about
right in this we should always be
thinking about okay where's the truth
because Hegel almost always pairs truth
and certainty together and the truth is
going to be more complex or at a higher
level than the mere certainty mere give
this height
so he says that what we have here is the
self it calls at the point of the self
into which the many points ourselves
through renouncing their own inner
certainty are fused into one through
having this absolute monarch the nobles
are giving something up they're engaging
in this process of flattery but they're
getting something they're all fused into
one thing they they find a locus a place
that has meaning for them a place where
they can really be the nobles that they
want to be you could say that the
absolute monarch provides them with the
stage with the backdrop against which
they can shine forth so how does this
play itself out then the things stop at
this point
Hegel says no he says this spirit proper
of state power consists in its obtaining
actuality and nourishment from the
sacrifice of action and thought by the
noble consciousness right we talked in
the previous paragraph about the noble
consciousnesses are in effect providing
recognition on air-cannon
to the unlimited monarch Hegel was going
to say that the unlimited monarch is
himself alienated now why is that the
case doesn't he enjoy everything
these are all sacrificing and these are
the best other people they're all
sacrificing in action and thought and in
language with flattery to this absolute
monarch why is he a lien ated that's a
good question
let's see what Hegel says he says the
spirit proper of state power consists in
obtaining actuality and nourishment from
the sacrifice and action of thought
it's an independence that is self
alienated the noble consciousness the
extreme the extreme of being for self
receives back
the other extreme that an actual
universality Hegel is not coming
straight out and saying it but the
absolute monarch the unlimited monarch
is losing something in the process I
mean you might think about this the app
that no no one single person can really
run the entire apparatus they need
something from these others and so the
the rest of the state is going back to
them in a certain respect so he says in
return for the universality of thought
which it relinquished the noble
consciousness is receiving actual
universality so he says in it that power
is first made truly effective in the
being for self of the noble
consciousness it ceases to be the inert
entity which it appeared to be the
extreme of abstract being for itself oh
yeah
being in itself rather so he says
considered as it is in itself state
power that is reflected into itself or
has become spirit simply means it has
become a moment of self-consciousness it
exists only as superseded as alpha
globin so we have a translation point
here we have a transcendence that is
taking place something important along
the way Hegel goes on and he says now
its essence in the form of something the
spirit of which is that it is to be
sacrificed and surrendered this is kind
of a big jump Hegel says it exists as
wealth now why should we be bringing in
wealth at this point why given the
dynamic that we've laid out here should
wealth reappear is it that well you've
always got economics taking place and we
kind of left that out for for the moment
no hegel hegel knows that Hegel knows
that if you want to have you know a
court you need taxes if you want to have
troops you got to have supply chains oh
yeah that's that's all true right but
wealth does something different
here why is wealth now connected with
the noble consciousness because the
noble consciousness has become for
itself in a different way than the being
for self of the unlimited monarch and
it's a way that is more like wealth
wealth is the way that Hegel is
discussing it here kind of
self-sacrificing
I mean he's got this wonderful phrase
where he says that we have a separate
and contingent individuality which is at
the mercy of every more powerful will
isn't that a great way to sort of
characterize the way that wealth works
wealth can be used for whatever purposes
we want whatever a person is willing
gets to decide what the money is going
to translate into right so there's an
analogy that's taking place here I'm not
sure that everyone will find it
completely convincing this transition
though so he says there we go it does
have a continuing existence as a reality
visa V wealth into which it is
ever-changing in accordance with its
notion but it is a reality whose notion
is just this process of passing over
which itself is part of the way wealth
works right state power is kind of
static by comparison to wealth because
when Heinkels talking about wealth he's
talking about not just you know hard
currency but exchange the entire process
that generates goods that that you know
swaps them between people that increases
over time so he says by way of the
service and honor done to it and from
which it derives its existence that was
what the Noble was working with before
into its opposite into the
relinquishment of power so the peculiar
self that is is its will knows that
through the debasement of the noble
consciousness it has become a
universality that renounces itself has
become a completely separate and
contingent individuality which is at the
mercy of every more powerful will the
noble consciousness is now at the point
of no longer truly being entirely the
noble consciousness because when it is
Noble it sacrifices
it's off to the state power and if it
gives everything that it's got its got
nothing left and then it's no longer
making a sacrifice of itself if it holds
something back that what that which it
holds back it's for itself is something
contingent the I that we were talking
about before which the next paragraph is
going to go into again for us so he says
what remains to it of universally
acknowledged and in communicable
independence is the empty name is he
talking here about the sovereign the
monarch who we saw was given a name a
name unlike any other name previously or
is he now talking about the name of the
noble it's it's not really clear just by
the passage I think that we should
interpret this as the name of the noble
rather than the name of sovereign
because that is where the dialectical
development is now taking place
you